this video is brought to you by
manscape.com
okay so spiderman no way home is right
around the corner but just before the
movie comes out i thought we'd do this
one more time and give our final
predictions and theories for the film
lots of stuff there is now out on the
movie and throughout this video we're
going to be going over what we know
whilst also trying to figure things out
from what's been shown in the trailers
and tv spots spoilers ahead if we're
right so if you don't want to know then
i suggest you move out the way like
girls do when toby mcguire is dancing
down the street please hit the thumbs up
button and also don't forget to
subscribe for videos like this every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into our no way home
predictions
now before we jump into that i just kind
of want to talk about the way the world
is right now i feel we very much live in
a two-tier society at this point and
honestly i'm just sick of all the
conspiracy theories misinformation and
people just saying whatever they want to
fit their agendas it's really sad seeing
family members and friends spouting off
complete nonsense and i can't wait until
this weekend when we see toby and andrew
are in the movie and this is over what
do you think i was talking about yeah so
at this point i think the first
prediction is that toby and andrew
garfield are definitely in the film
there's been so many leaks mistakes in
the trailers and at this point i'd bet
mcgran's house on it yes granny off to
the old people's home you go now the
iconography used in the trailers and tv
sports is clearly aping things from
earlier iterations such as us getting
first-person views of each spider-man
which we see happening in the bridge
scene we also have things like the
goblin mask being trashed and left
behind whilst he runs down an alley
which is somewhat reminiscent of the
scene from spider-man 2. there's so much
in them i think to the point that it's
at least paying homage to the point it
all seems to be done to foreshadow them
coming in beyond that though i was
talking to ryan airy about this the
other day and we actually think that
there could be more spider people in it
that we don't know about yet toby and
andrew have pretty much taken up all the
talking points but i'd love to see
someone like emma stone showing up as
spider-gwen if nicholas cage showed up
as spider-man noir i think that the
cinema would explode and potentially
this could be what's being hindered in
the trailer when strange says he can't
stop them coming through i think that
toby and andrew will be in a good chunk
of the film and they won't just show up
for the final battle like the marketing
is leading us to believe i'd love it if
this multiversal portal brought across
people from the spider-verse and though
that's a long shot i think it would work
really well now though we are expecting
a lot of major twists and turns i think
that the movie will be pretty
straightforward i can imagine that the
film will open right after the events
are far from home as has been shown in
some of the clips and from there peter
will hand himself in get off because of
matt murdock then go to strange
interrupt the spell and bring the
villains from the trailer into the mcu
this will include him coming face to
face with dr octopus who i'm guessing
will be stopped by the nanotech
interacting with his tentacles which
will then allow him to once more control
the ai he'll go to the sanctuary prison
and will become somewhat of an ally i
think from this point on we'll watch his
peter goes to stop electro is
interrupted by the sandman and he'll
then capture them both he'll then meet
the goblin and we'll learn that all the
villains died because of the spider-man
of their universe peter will then steal
a magic cube that's holding them in
place and there'll be a chase in the
mirror dimension between peter and
strange which will allow the villains to
have time to escape goblin will then
probably go after aunt may and i'm
guessing that in the scene with the bomb
blasts that she will be killed we do
catch her in the lobby running towards
someone and this is right beside where
the goblin throws the bomb and peter
jumps after it we can see that it
destroys the entire lobby i think this
moment will tie in with a shot of happy
sitting outside in his car looking
completely devastated now green goblin
did go after aunt may in the rainy
trilogy and to me it makes sense that
he'd do this in the film as she's such a
close person in peter's life in the
civil war storyline after peter's
identity is revealed antme ends up
almost getting killed and then peter
goes to strange to cast a spell to save
there it seems like the movie is loosely
pulling from these story lines and
adapting them to something new but at
this point i don't think that may is
gonna make it out alive
now peter escapes the goblin bomb with a
really close shave and speaking of close
shaves we've teamed up with manscape to
bring you that all new in one
performance package 4.0 i've been using
their stuff for a year now and it's made
a massive difference when it comes to
trimming my peter parker
[Music]
the lawnmower 4.0 is the sleekest
electric trimmer manscaped have ever
released and not only is it waterproof
but it comes with advanced skin safe
technology that provides a shave more
stylized than tony stark's beard it also
has a super smart cordless charging
system that gives you power for 90
minutes and led lights that make it look
like it's powered by the arc reactor
with it is an amazing travel lock
feature as well so it doesn't set off
when you're on the go and all you have
to do to activate it is click the button
three times on top of this the pack also
has two products that i never even knew
are needed until now that is the crop
preservable deodorant spray and crop
reviver ball toner spray simply apply
the crop preserver after a shower for
all day body odor protection and use the
crop reviver on your infinity stones at
any time of the day now i'm going to be
honest yeah i've got got a bit of a big
big nose here but the weed whacker has
been a complete life changer it's got
the same skin safe technology that the
lawnmower does so you don't have to
worry about cutting or tugging on
sensitive hairs and it just cleans all
them out now for a limited time only if
you get this you get two free gifts
including the anti-chafing boxer briefs
and a travel bag that puts a suit of
armor around your kit wherever you go go
to manscape.com right now and get 20 off
free international shipping and two
gifts as well when you enter heavy 20 at
the checkout it's the perfect time of
year to get one of these amazing kits
for yourself your partner your best
friend someone you know guy down the
road anyone will love this so definitely
go check it out cheers now the spell is
going to be a big part of the movie and
my theory is that though it won't work
early on in the film that they'll
attempt it again at the end and it will
this is something that we've guessed
that in a lot of our previous videos one
of which i'll play right now now
speaking of the spell after watching the
trailer several times and really sitting
on it i actually think that it does
indeed wipe mj's memory and peter is
pretty much completely alone in who
knows that he's spider-man why i say
this is because of the behind-the-scenes
images and footage of the film in which
we see peter going to meet the character
now because he's not getting mobbed i
guess everything works but it looks like
he's asking her out on a date i think it
would be kind of heartbreaking if it
turned out that she no longer remembered
him and this is basically them having to
start the entire relationship again i
also think this could end up happening
with ned happy and possibly even the
avengers leaving peter alone to go and
do his own thing with sony sorry in the
mcu now why this could be the case is
because that's also how things sort of
go in the comics after ant mays but in
critical condition peter goes to strange
for help because may is short on time
strange ends up playing out several
timelines at once in which we see that
there's no one who can help her thus
peter leaves the sanctuarium but it's at
this point that he comes across mephisto
who says that he'll save mae's life but
in return he wants peter and mary jane's
marriage peter and mary jane sacrificed
their love in order to save may and when
we see them again they know each other
but can't ever remember being in love
peter also makes a deal with mephisto so
that people will also forget that he's
spider-man as if they didn't then
assassins would just come after him
again and his friends and family would
be put in the firing line now we know
from what's being said on the next
spider-man trilogy that it'll be a lot
different to this one and i think that
peter will go to college and pretty much
be on his own i'd love to see them bring
the black suit into it at this point and
if we get tom hardy interacting with him
that would be great they've clearly set
the symbiote up so if peter got the
black suit he could pretty much become
someone completely different in his
college years if mj ends up forgetting
they were in love that also leaves the
door open for characters like black cat
and gwen stacy to come into the mcu as
well now i kind of get the feeling that
right after the statue of liberty fight
that strange will do the second spell in
the trailers and tv spots it looks like
strange is casting one and then this
blasts over the entire city if you
compare it to the way that the spell
looks the first time strange tries to
cast it you'll see that it moves in a
very similar way just before it fails
there's a thing at the statue of liberty
that he'll do this spell once more after
sending the villains back to their own
realities this could happen right after
peter kisses mj in the daytime and it
would also explain why he says do it in
the tv spots i know a lot of people
think that he's gonna end up going to
another universe but i can't see the
character leaving the mcu completely
just for this from the looks of it this
kiss in the daytime could be their final
one before all is forgotten and that
would explain why strangers casting
runes in the sky during this scene it
looks like it's taking place after the
statue of liberty fight as mj is wearing
the same clothes and peter is beat up so
doing the spell there makes a lot of
sense when we see peter in the behind
the scenes stuff it's clearly taking
place in winter due to the snow so the
timeline makes sense for them to have
been apart for a long time the first
spider-man movie had a great ending that
showed spider-man would rather give up
the love of his life than put her in any
danger and add to that gwen and you can
kind of see how toby and andrew would
rub off on tom in the comics after their
break up mary jane actually went on
today brad and he was introduced and far
from home as well so potentially that
could be the way things are heading so
yeah i think the spell will be cast once
more at the end without peter
interrupting or stipulating things and
this will remove pretty much all of the
relationships that he has now i think
the film is pretty much gonna have the
pace of infinity war where it's just
boom boom boom plot point to plot point
and like i've said i think it's gonna be
very straightforward i think after all
the stuff i mentioned earlier that
andrew and toby will be brought across
after the chase scene and then from
there we'll go to the statue of liberty
the villains will get taken down and
then sent home along with the heroes who
now will no longer want to kill them in
their realities and thus they'll be
saved in some way peter will then ask
strange to do this spell once more and
we'll have somewhat of a tragic ending
with him not only losing may but also
the people closest to him now i love it
if we got another villain in order to
make the sinister six and though it
seems unlikely scorpion would be my pick
for that homecoming of course ended with
michael manno's matt gawkin asking
adrian toombs who spider-man was and
then far from home ended with his
identity being out there thus a thing it
would pay off to have him hunting peter
in the third film and as he knows this
reality he could act as somewhat of a
guide to the rest of the villains anyway
those are all our predictions and
theories and if you're watching this
before seeing the movie then let us know
yours below if you're from the future
and have now seen it then let us know
what we got right and what we didn't
if any if anything i don't think we've
got anything right but you've watched
the video now now obviously i'd love to
hear your thoughts though so make sure
you comment below and let me know we are
in competition right now and giving away
three copies of the spider-man 4k
trilogies on the 30th of december and
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the video we pick the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now serve that's you then message
me on twitter heavyspoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of some of
the coolest easter eggs in spider-man
into the spider-verse i'll be linked on
screen right now and hopefully i see you
over there but if not tell you what mate
go do one if you do go watch it i love
you for the rest of my life and i hope
you enjoy the rest of the week and the
movie you take care of yourself peace